thank you for joining us i'm john
langley we do start with a developing
story happening now in the southwest
valley
metro police are investigating an
apparent murder suicide there they've
been there for several hours
bianca holman live near the scene of
blue diamond in fort apache with the
latest from detectives bianca
you can see that part of this housing
development is blocked off with yellow
tape metro
is still on scene investigating what
happened just before 8 this morning
yellow tape still blocking the area
around the house we're told a teen in
the home called 9-1-1
the teen said he could hear gunshots
coming from inside the house
he found his mother in the upstairs
hallway with a gunshot wound
and then at the bottom of the stairs he
saw his father also suffering from
gunshot wounds
we believe to have occurred is that this
is a murder-suicide investigation
that was a result of an argument taking
place inside of the
house now police say the husband shot
his wife first then turned the gun
himself both were in their mid 40s and
as you can imagine this is a very
traumatic and upsetting situation
there was some family that arrived on
scene and metro says they do have trauma
experts for them now lieutenant ray
spencer shares that
if you are feeling overwhelmed and
stressed that there are numbers
available 2-1-1 to be exact or
the family justice center reporting from
near blue diamond
and fort apache bianca holman 8 news now
all right bianca thank you very much